le préfet de police didier lallement et
sur le coup d'une enquête pour faux
témoignage
quatre autres personnalités issues de la
haute magistrature sont également visés
dans cette procédure initiée par le
parquet de nanterre en cause de faux
témoignage lors de la commission d'
enquête parlementaire sur l'indépendance
de la justice présidée par le député
insoumis ugo bernalicis en septembre il
avait saisi le procureur de la
république de paris pour de supposées
parjure en effet toutes les
personnalités qui s'expriment devant les
commissions parlementaires prête serment
monsieur je vous invite donc à lever la
main droite est à dire je le jure je le
jure je le jure monsieur le président
mes propos contestés de didier lallement
concerne l'attitude des forces de
l'ordre lors des manifestations non
autorisées didier lallement avait
expliqué qu'il avait fait mettre en
garde à vue dès gilet jaune ou autres
militants antiracistes qui avait appelé
à se regrouper dans la rue sans avoir
l'autorisation
alors go bernalicis avait demandé s'il
avait fait de même avec les
syndicalistes policiers qui avaient
organisé des manifestations non
autorisées à paris en juin
voici la réponse de didier lallement
vous voyez pas de sujets sur les
manifestations appelées par les
organisations syndicales quand elles ne
sont pas déclarés ou je pense notamment
manifestation des policiers récemment la
nuit depuis trois nuits de suite devant
les institutions
je n'ai pas trouvé les organisateurs
n'était pourtant pas très difficile de
les identifier dans le cortège pour rémi
heitz les propos litigieux concerne une
note intitulée permanence gilet jaune
contenant des instructions qui aurait
donné le procureur elle conseillé de ne
pas lever la garde à vue pour certains
manifestants avant la fin de la
mobilisation
à l'époque le syndicat national de la
magistrature avait dénoncé une atteinte
aux libertés individuelles un
détournement de la garde à vue
voici ce qu'explique rémi heitz je vais
vous répondre très clairement sur cette
note
déjà vous observerez que cette note
personne ne l'a vu
c'est ce qui est un peu curieux c'est
que cette note elle n'existe pas pour
être clair le procureur de la république
de paris n'a pas signé une note
avec des instructions à ses collègues en
leur disant de faire quelque chose non
pourtant un peu plus tard rémy heitz
admet avoir fourni un mémento de bonnes
pratiques concernant notamment la garde
à vue ce qui revient strictement au même
et puis trois autres hautes
personnalités de la magistrature ont été
signalés par ugo bernalicis cette fois
ci dans le cadre de la sphère fillon
mais voyons ce que pense le député du
nord insoumis de cette enquête c'est une
bonne nouvelle en soi une enquête soit
ouverte alors ça sera à charge et à
décharge ne sera pas quelle sera l'issue
est à limite peu importe l'issue
l'objectif pour le parlementaire que je
suis le président de commission denquête
que j'étais sur les obstacles
indépendance du pouvoir j'ai dit c'est
que on prenne au sérieux la
représentation nationale l'assemblée
nationale ce qu'est une commission
denquête parce que qui on peut venir du
moins une commission denquête mentir et
repartir comme si de rien n'était enfin
tout ça ne sert plus à rien on est quand
même la représentation nationale
il existe un précédent récent alexandre
benallal ancien monsieur sécurité d'
emmanuel macron s'était exprimé devant
une commission sénatoriale
eh bien les parlementaires avaient
estimé qu'il avait peut-être tenu des
propos mensongers dont il l'avait
signalé
pour cela ils pouvaient risquer jusqu'à
cinq ans de prison et 75000 euros
d'amendé
mais finalement le parquet de paris
avait décidé de classer l affaire sans
suite
est ce que le parquet de nanterre où est
dépaysé la sphère sera moins clément